[Música]
les invito a hacer un viaje en el tiempo
conmigo
hasta la prehistoria hasta los orígenes
del ser humano
en este contexto les voy a pedir que se
imaginen a dos personajes señor
felicidad
y el señor miedo señor felicidad señor
felicidades el coach de la prehistoria
siempre piensa en positivo si el señor
felicidad quiere puede ver un mamut dice
ay me subo yo salgo ni zona de confort
me hago self y 14 millones de seguidores
en pre instagram tiene tres días en
comer
dieta paleolítica ayuno intermitente
tableta
y el señor miedo el pobre hombre es
justamente lo contrario siempre
interpreta en negativo siempre está
pensando en las posibles catástrofes que
le pueden ocurrir escucha un ruido dice
esto van a ser siete dientes de sable
que vienen caminando por la sabana
africana a tres patas porque la única
comida disponible en toda áfrica somos
mi familia
va a seguir de la cueva dice si me da un
golpe de calor si me da un golpe de
calor y aquellos buitres que vi hace 45
días me desmayo piensan que estoy muerto
y me comen vivo
es suenan como verán son dos formas de
interpretar la realidad realmente
distintas pero pese a todo son amigos y
un día van por la sabana africana en
busca de comida caminando y escuchan un
ruido al lado matorral señor felicidad
dirige su atención en pie hace sus
cánticos y rituales a los dioses de la
caza hace sus ejercicios de
empoderamiento de programación
neurobiológica empoderamiento físico
cuántico remediación al es relieve un
par de capítulos de quien me ha robado
la felicidad cómo recuperarla en 45
segundos
se lanza
el señor miedo está a 3 km
quien creen que tiene más posibilidades
de sobrevivir a largo plazo
pues el señor felicidad seguramente de
vez en cuando que hacer presas
impresionantes e incluso igual escribe
un libro y lo cuenta pero es cuestión de
tiempo que se lo merendó y una
característica de ser comido es que no
te reproduce es más y si no te reproduce
apunten si no te reproduce es más
tus genes no pasan a la siguiente
generación así que efectivamente todos
los que estamos aquí somos los nietos de
los nietos de los nietos de los que
tenían miedo
llevamos en el código genético el miedo
la tristeza la ira el estrés
necesitamos experimentar estas emociones
imagínense estoy en un entierro y estoy
contento
sí estoy contento un entierro puede
pasar dos cosas o que la persona que se
ha muerto no me hacía ninguna gracia y
heredó
o me encierran en un psiquiátrico o el
amor de mi vida tiene novio y el tipo
más alto que yo no puedo estar contento
con esto o les juro que esto es verídico
hace tres cuatro meses nos preparaba la
charla
reunión de trabajo de estas que
condicionan tu vida laboral 45 años me
visto de punta en blanco bajo las
escaleras y para en un semáforo
y por el destino por las leyes del karma
de audouin de ala de que se yo en la
trayectoria de la rueda delantera
derecha de un coche hay una bolsita de
ketchup de tres centímetros por dos
centímetros pasa por encima y las leyes
de la física hacen que todo el contenido
de la bolsita vaya directamente a mi
camisa blanca
no puedo estar contento en esta
situación necesitamos experimentar
emociones incómodas nuestro cerebro nos
ayuda a sobrevivir no a ser felices no
sabido adaptarnos al medio
hace algunos años me ofrecieron el
trabajo de mi vida buen sueldo en
horario trabajar como psicólogo vivir en
la playa
es cierto que me tenía que desplazar de
mi ciudad natal pero vivir al lado de la
playa estaba muy bien y yo soy un hombre
de éxito iba a signo por la calle y
realmente no supe ver que a lo mejor
aquello se trataba de un caramelo
envenenado había detalles muy sutiles
solamente captables por las mentes más
avispadas de de la tierra y uno de estos
detalles era que durante las dos
primeras semanas de formación todo el
mundo me decía más o menos lo mismo
decía
a ver
eres joven no tienes hijos no tienes
hipoteca porque te empeñas en amargarte
la vida trabajando aquí pero yo no leía
entre en líneas no nada al volante y
dejé pasar días meses años y nuestra
distancia la de la empresa la mía cada
vez era mayor ellos tenían unos
principios casi puramente económicos
como es lógico o empresa yo tenía unos
principios pues de dar todo el bienestar
en general bienestar salud mental en
todo el que llegaba y yo cada vez me
sentía más frustrado sentía más
estresado me sentía que no era mi sitio
no abres katz que tú eres psicólogo
protocolo de felicidad al mal tiempo
buena cara'
salimos de la zona de confort si pienso
en positivo me ocurrirán cosas positivas
todas estas cosas y saben lo que
conseguí con esta nueva actitud con este
nuevo paradigma de vida
tuve la gran suerte de caer en una
depresión
y es que nuestro cerebro funciona como
una gran empresa imagínense un edificio
las plantas más bajas tenemos aquellos
departamentos que se dedican a las
funciones más primitivas más automáticas
seguir respirando el control de la
temperatura si carme la boca cuando es
hablando en público estas cosas un
poquito más arriba tenemos el
departamento de emociones el
departamento emociones se ocupa de
ayudarnos a responder ante las demandas
del medio para que sobrevivamos y más
arriba está la corteza cerebral ahí
estamos nosotros pensamiento abstracto
lenguaje toma de decisiones y ahí en
nuestra oficina no contó el skyline de
la ciudad nos sentimos importantes
creemos que tenemos todo bajo control
y parafraseando una metáfora de un
profesor de la universidad complutense
de madrid de gonzalo hervás la cuenta
mucho mejor que yo por supuesto estamos
un día nuestra oficina y el skyline y
entra un mail en el asunto pone tristeza
departamento emociones tristeza
depresión sufrimiento y otro lo abro yo
sigo me toma decisiones fundamentales
para medir el café sólo con leche solo
otro email urgente tristeza
están directos a no quiero saber nada de
esto sigo me toma decisiones sin azúcar
para no empiezan a llamar a la puerta ya
sé quién es no pienso abrir será tocar
cada vez más fuerte voy a abrir yo meto
bajo la mesa siguen llamando siguen
llamando y pum
tiran la puerta abajo y entra todo el
departamento de emociones con antorchas
dispuestos a quemarme la oficina ya
tomar el control
y es que si nos empeñamos en no escuchar
lo que nuestro cerebro nos está gritando
éste subirá el volumen para hacerse
escuchar mientras que si ante el primer
email
abrimos experimentamos la emoción
experimentamos la sensación y después la
gestionamos durará unos minutos unas
horas unos días el problema es que la
mayoría de nosotros no tenemos ni idea
ni de gestionar la tristeza y
probablemente tengamos muchos mails sin
abrir
una de las claves cuando llegamos
emociones es que lo único que
conseguimos es que éstas incrementen su
frecuencia su intensidad y su duración
porque dura tampoco la alegría nos
abrimos a la alegría si esto lo bloqueó
no tenemos que tener en cuenta que la
sociedad los últimos 10 mil 15 mil años
ha evolucionado muchísimo hemos pasado a
ser recolectores cazadores nómadas vivir
en cuevas vivir en árboles a vivir en
ciudades a vivir en centros comerciales
que ocurre que el ambiente es muy
distinto al cual evolucionamos con lo
cual muchas veces nuestras emociones son
falsas alarmas por ejemplo mi cuerpo
ahora mismo me está mandando miedo
ansiedad y me está pidiendo que vaya
corriendo pero en realidad no hay
peligro de muerte si no me salgo de
círculos y me decís
hasta el francotirador
entonces qué ocurre que cuanto más
intentemos evitar nuestras emociones va
a ir a peor
en un momento de mi vida en la etapa
hasta que les contaba ya no es que mi
cuerpo demandas y emails si no es que me
escribía whatsapp up interest a
instagram escriba privados de facebook
abría la nevera que la depresión es
depresión deja el trabajo iba
conduciendo o si gaga era increíble y me
vi una mañana a mí mismo a las cinco y
cuarto en la ducha llorando como una
magdalena y pegando puñetazos al muro y
jefe igual tengo que abrir el email y
ese día es cuando ya tomé conciencia
pero tengo buenas noticias que llevo
diez minutos contando penas
se puede mejorar nuestra inteligencia
emocional todos podemos mejorar nuestra
relación con el departamento de abajo
pero para ello tenemos que empezar a
abrirnos las emociones además lo que nos
dice la ciencia de las personas con alta
inteligencia emocional es que tienen
mayor ajuste psicológico están mejor
adaptadas al medio mayores niveles de
bienestar fíjense que si no evitamos
emociones estamos mejor mayores niveles
de salud mental y también de salud
física porque somatizan menos por
ejemplo en el trabajo gestiona mucho
mejor el estrés e incluso los jefes con
alta inteligencia emocional que hay
algunos son valorados con mejores
líderes tienes que encima esta gente
construir relaciones sociales de mayor
calidad al ser empáticos más empáticos
saben lo que necesitan los demás saben
pedir lo que necesitan ellos
en familia en amigos y en pareja también
pero una de las claves como les llevo
diciendo mucho rato es que dejemos de
tratar de evitar de negar cómo nos
sentimos
si yo levanto por las mañanas me pongo
delante el espejo empiezo soy muy guapo
soy muy guapo soy muy guapo mi cerebro
no es ni ciego ni tonto lo único voy a
conseguir con esto es generar una
disonancia entre lo que me estoy
diciendo y lo que estoy sintiendo y
estoy viendo y qué voy a hacer voy a
prestar atención a aquello que me falta
voy a empezar a dar vueltas me a sentir
muchísimo peor y la sociedad les va a
presionar la sociedad los medios siempre
no teniendo tienes que ser feliz tienes
que ser feliz parece que sentimos
tristeza ansiedad somos unos fracasos
parece que tenemos teletubbies puestos
de éxtasis el día de navidad todo el día
cada segundo de nuestra miserable vida
tengo que sonreír y les dio una cosa
es necesario experimentar emociones
incómodas nos ayuda a adaptarnos
cuando por fin conseguí desvincular
media que yo que les contaba que la
tranquilidad
me echaron
el amor era mutuo
fue recuerdo el último día cuando ya no
tenía que volver más estaba por la
treintena sensación de plenitud me la
han echado historia del sofá como y
recuerda es acción de plenitud y delante
de mí no tenía nada es decir no tenía ni
idea que hacer con mi vida había abierto
un blog hacía un par de meses que no
leía nadie obviamente y realmente dije
bueno a ver qué hacemos y vamos a montar
un gabinete psicología qué es lo que tú
sabes hacer de psicología basada en la
evidencia científica y además vas a
contar con un equipo de personas que
realmente estén preocupadas por la salud
mental de los demás
y ese camino es el camino que empecé ese
día me ha traído hasta aquí hasta el
otro lado del atlántico y estoy aquí
para decirles solamente una cosa que me
gustaría que recordarse y es que tratar
de evitar tratar de negar nuestras
emociones incómodas es el camino más
corto hacia el malestar y hacia las
enfermedades mentales escuchen a sus
cuerpos abran sus emails
[Aplausos]